what is the
like current relationship with uzi
because you know i mean
everything's kind of in public that
there's obviously some disagreements and
you know what is your guys's current
relationship with him
he signed a generation now um
he pretty much does his thing you know
and like
we support it and allow it and you know
i'm very proud of him yeah
yeah yeah i mean it's pretty much like
the basic you know like record label
artist situation you know he he's at a
state where
he likes to kind of control his own
creative thing which he's always you
know been a part of other than canon
being super hands-on
and uh pretty much he controls the
timing is the dynamic like
change between everybody like when like
like i mean obviously you know
i feel like you guys kind of brought
them up in the game
right and then there's obviously a
disconnect that happened like it's
always human nature you know what i mean
that
that's what happens you know you seen
them with the best you know
dr dre and snoop like there was no real
problem you know
people put out there but it's just like
when you become an artist you can
even me as a part con producer at some
point
when you have the success you'll be like
yeah i did this you know
i did this so you know i mean so i you
know i ran into those things where
you know honestly nobody know the story
in 2008
i was feeling myself and i kind of left
them out yeah i remember that
in the cold and i was just like you know
obviously it was it was something
between us that
had nothing to do with them but it was
just like man i do
i could do it on my
multiple times and i i just always
thought when we see each other it's
gonna be
it's it's gonna be something you know
what i mean i'm just with me it's me and
my cousin
it was 10 12 deep you know wow and we
were always cool we see each other and
it would
it would be cordial until you know me
and dram just sat down i was like
i think we use that jersey mics or
something yeah mice
and by the time we got like what we even
talk about it's just nothing
you know what i'm saying so it always
happens with this stuff and you know as
you make music
uh things happen people want to do
things
i think with uzi 2 with our situation is
that
obviously on our end we would never have
wanted
any of it to play out in the public you
know i think a lot of
artists and record labels go through
similar situations
i feel like it's just kind of like a
generational thing like the first thing
when people get angry
what's the generational thing because of
social media right right yeah of course
that's how they yeah express themselves
that's how they express themselves and
you know
from on our end like you know we never
you know we never really even went on a
platform and you know defended ourselves
or
you know anything like that and we just
we didn't really want that you know what
i'm saying
i mean obviously one we didn't want to
be painted as
no bad guys you know what i'm saying but
i mean i'm sure the fan like his fans
are crazy right oh yeah it was it was
killing
social media i i had to take a a pause
you know
thank you uzi like i definitely had to
like get off for a quick minute but you
know
i mean it's crazy just you know i don't
get any of that anymore but it's like
you know we wanted to
we've been in this business so long you
know our reputations are everything yes
of course so clearly
you know i guess more than anything you
know we let tom tell you know what i'm
saying and
you know morning like again he he's he's
family he's our artist so you know
we don't want anything but the best for
him you know what i'm saying you guys
want him to be
you feel what i'm saying so it was like
for us we just had to allow you know
we just had to let it play out and you
know fans are going to say what they're
going to say or people are going to
have their interpretation who don't know
us per se and you know it is what it is
like i think
did you guys get like a blunt of the
blame from fans for
eternal to take taking a blunt all of it
absolutely jesus
what was like the story as to why it
took so long like if you don't mind
getting into it like
what's the story or why did it like why
did it take so long was it was it you
know because i think that
he literally put the album out when he
wanted to that's the craziest part about
everything like
i tell you when like you guys were
holding them up and i mean this is the
most basic thing
that i tell everybody like we are in the
business of selling music you know what
i'm saying so there is no benefit to us
to hold anything of course not yeah it's
just not even logical you know i'm
saying like we don't eat if music
doesn't come out
you know so like i don't know what power
struggle or what pride like would allow
us to even do something like that
so ultimately like for real these guys
put music out sometimes they come to us
two days before
that used to be i mean because remember
we came
at the transition from the physical age
to the digital end
so i remember when cannon would come to
me and be like yo this kid wants to put
a project out
tomorrow and i'd have to clear 10 beats
you know and so on and so forth like
it's literally a feeling and when they
have the feeling like
they call me and the [ __ ] has to come
out you know what i'm saying so we don't
really get any benefit from
like withholding or like saying
something can or can't come out you know
when it's ready we're ready for that
[ __ ] to come out too
yeah i mean like like he dropped pretty
much what two two albums and
you know back to back is that i i wonder
too because like
you know obviously your guys's kind of
situation is in public i
i in my head i thought is he trying to
put out like is he trying to get out of
his deal as quick as possible
because you know there's like draco dude
like drake you know did that with the
you know like like p artists have done
that you know
in in in the past like when when or is
it just the deluxe play because he kind
of low-key
deluxe play off yeah yeah just i think
he's just just a deluxe player
yeah i think it's just something you
want to get off and i don't think he
wanted to keep both vibes
in that name so it was like one one half
of the album was kind of like
the first mixtape we added
uzi versus the world so he didn't want
to keep everything because
i think the eternal taki he just wanted
to have like this you know zan and
right right right it's just something
you know